Галопом за один день Верховна Рада ухвалила закон про імпічмент президента.
Те, що обіцяв Володимир Зеленський ще під час виборів.
Депутати від "Слуги народу" запевняють:
цим глава держави підтверджує і свою рівність перед законом.
Цим президент демонструє насамперед відданість своїм словам
і те, що він готовий отримати ті самі рівні умови щодо
притягнення президента як інституції до відповідальності
в порядку, який визначений законом.
Щоб ухвалити закон про імпічмент, парламентській більшості знадобилося лише півгодини.
Документ передбачає, що депутати можуть усунути президента виключно в разі вчинення ним
державної зради або іншого злочину.
Процедура наступна.
Спочатку проста більшість, тобто 226 депутатів, ініціюють імпічмент письмовим поданням.
Цей документ має містити правове обґрунтування створення спеціальної тимчасової слідчої комісії,
яка розслідуватиме факт і обставини державної зради або іншого злочину, вчинених президентом.
Обвинувальний висновок слідчої комісії має схвалити конституційна більшість -
щонайменше 300 депутатів.
Якщо це відбудеться, то далі документ передають до Конституційного Суду
та Верховного Суду України.
Для перевірки щодо дотримання конституційної процедури та для отримання висновку,
чи є в діяннях, які закидають президенту, ознаки державної зради або іншого злочину.
Якщо і цей етап пройде позитивно, то остаточно затвердити імпічмент
та усунути главу держави від влади мають три чверті обранців - щонайменше 338 депутатів.
Отже, вперше окремим законом чітко регулюються процедурні моменти звільнення президента.
Утім, майже всі ці положення взяті зі статті 111 Конституції України і регламенту Верховної Ради.
Проблеми були лише у визначенні чіткої процедури імпічменту,
а також - навколо створення і діяльності ТСК.
Їх, на думку експертів, можна було б покращити і без окремого закону.
Нині ж попри новий закон процедура імпічменту не стає простішою.
По-перше, для остаточного імпічменту президента потрібно все ще забагато голосів у Раді - 338.
Ця норма зберігається в Конституції вже понад 20 років.
В умовах, коли монобільшість у парламенті є пропрезидентською,
імпічмент навіть теоретично неможливий.
Окрім того, юридично процедура надто складна,
передбачає багато кроків і може розтягнутися на роки.
Ба більше, термін роботи слідчої комісії в законі передбачений - не більше шести місяців.
А от строку розгляду Конституційним і Верховним судами обвинувального вироку щодо президента -
немає.
Таким чином, імпічмент може розтягнутися аж до закінчення терміну повноважень президента.
Президент Зеленський виконав свою обіцянку і вніс до парламенту закон щодо імпічменту президента.
Він дійсно нормалізує процедуру звільнення очільника держави.
Утім, юридично і фактично він аж ніяк не спрощує імпічмент президента.